- All right y'all I
can't close out the show
without serving up one more
thing to make you go, "Aww."
This is "What I'm Liking."
(audience applauding)
Okay, so we all know breakups suck,
but 22-year-old Kenzie from San Francisco
has discovered the perfect
cure, all thanks to her dad.
Just check out this TikTok post.
(gentle music)
As genuinely sweet as the video is,
the comments are even better.
One person wrote, "Striving
to be as good as this dad
when I have kids."
Another one said, "He's
showing you the type of man
that you should settle for."
Well first of all don't settle.
That wasn't the word you
maybe should have used,
but we have...
Just my thoughts.
We have Kenzie on the line
right now, what's up Kenzie?
(audience applauding)
- Hi Kelly, so nice to meet you.
- I love your hair, it's
shorter now, that's so cute.
Your dad seems amazing.
Is this like a tradition,
that if you ever have a breakup
he takes you to Disneyland.
It's a beautiful thing.
- [Kenzie] Well I don't know
if it was supposed to be a tradition,
but I'm definitely going
to make it a tradition now.
- So what have you learned from the video
going viral though?
Do you realize how lucky you
are to have a dad like that,
that's so cool.
- Yeah.
So basically I had this Minnie
Mouse doll when I was little,
and my parents passed it down to me
from a daughter they had before me
who died when she was a baby.
And so I was never able to meet my sister,
and I felt that this Minnie
Mouse was the only connection
I was gonna ever have to her.
So I just became obsessed
with Minnie Mouse
and all things Disneyland.
So Disneyland is just like a
really, really special place
for me and my whole
family because of that.
- Wow.
- And so my first breakup in
high school my dad was like,
"I need to cheer her up."
And so he took me to the
happiest place on earth
and it worked like a charm.
Come my second big breakup in college,
he knew exactly what to do
this time, he'd learned.
And he took me to
Disneyland again this time.
My mom came along as well
and we all just experience
the magic together.
- Aw that's so sweet.
I love your family.
And that's a beautiful full circle moment
with the Minnie Mouse thing
and tying you with Disneyland.
That's a beautiful thing that
your family will have forever.
Thank you so much for sharing with us.
(audience applauding)
- Of course.
- All right, I'm liking your post girl.
And that's not all,
our season partner Pilot
Pin makers of Friction,
the go to erase pin of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and just being rad in general,
so they're gonna give you $1000,
how's that sound?
(audience applauding)
- What?
(Kelly laughing)
My God, that's like (indistinct) awesome.
- You got lots of trips
to Disneyland on that.